Leo you're my favorite boy I wrote that
for him when I was pregnant with him and
I used to sing it to him Keke Palmer
singing a personalized lullaby for baby
leotis oh my gosh yes sup yes
during an interview with Amazon music
the actress opens up about the tunes she
sings her little one to sleep I do the
typical ones I do like uh Twinkle
Twinkle Little Star before revealing she
wrote a special one just for him but
then I made him his own little song too
yeah Kiki isn't shy about giving fans a
snippet of the original
Leo you're my favorite boy Leo you're my
pride and joy we know there's no one
else that makes me feel the way that you
do and there's no one in this world that
can never make me feel like the old
you're my favorite boy then it goes back
and down and that sweet track has the
internet wanting an album from the Star
oh my gosh come on let's talk about it I
wrote that for him when he was uh when I
was pregnant with him and I used to sing
it to him whether it's customized or a
classic Kiki is all for serenading her
bundle of joy
[Music]
since welcoming leotis in February the
new mamas continuing to bask in the joys
of motherhood you already know while
also getting real about her struggles as
a first time off I had to pump it out
this was crazy it really hurt I just
came on here to say
if you are a single parent
pull out your cape but when it comes to
raising a kid I've already learned that
it takes a village
um and sometimes that's a privilege and
I just want anybody out there that is a
single parent that's been doing this
um friends of mine people that I don't
know family members of mine
I'm really in my in my heart
bring tears to my eyes I am just truly
profoundly impressed you have my respect
sister despite it all Kiki's got lots of
love for Baby Leo Leo you're my favorite
boy Leo you're my pride and joy we know
there's no one else that makes me feel
the way that you do
I've been around a long long time I've
seen some things I can't Define
[Music]
thank you